[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es meinem saftigen
schokoladen boden das ist ein
grundrezept und auch dieses video könnt
ihr immer wieder zurückgreifen wenn ihr
mal ein sagt dem schokoladen boden
möchte und hielten auch schon die
zutaten bereit
ihr benötigt ja ja die habe ich ganz
sauber getrennt in eiweiß und eigelb
außerdem eine prise salz zimmer warme
butter vanille extrakt mail speisestärke
backpulver bei kakao natürlich zucker
und milch für einen richtig saftigen
boden brauchen wir immer eine separate
aufgeschlagene baiser masse und die
erhaltet ihr indem ihr eiweiß mit zucker
steif stark ich mache das immer so dass
ich das sommer getrennte eiweiß in meine
saubere und fettfreie schüsse gebe habt
ihr den schneebesen aufsatz dran und
gibt da noch eine prise salz mit hinzu
das hilft einfach dass wir diese
struktur schneller zerstören und sich
das einfach viel besser aufschlägt nach
zirka einer minute dass sich die hälfte
des zuckers einrieseln
[Musik]
nach zwei minuten mit dem zucker city
massiert so aus also richtig schön fest
und die gebe ich jetzt nur ganz kurz an
die seite und wechsel jetzt einmal die
schüsseln aus und in die schüssel gebe
ich jetzt butter die sollte wie gesagt
zimmer warm sein und den restlichen
zucker und dann dass ich das auf
höchster stufe circa zwei minuten lang
aufschlagen nach zwei minuten könnt ihr
deutlich erkennen dass die themen
schönheit geworden ist und einfach
weniger ist und an der stelle einfach
die elbe nach und nach einer breiten und
gerne auch mit der stufe ein bisschen
runter gehen
[Musik]
das vanille extrakt habe ich jetzt auch
schon eingearbeitet der kein vanille
extrakt da hat der kann es entweder bei
uns im shop kaufen und in der infobox
klicken oder in dem vanillezucker aber
man muss sagen wenn ein extrakt ist
einfach viel viel intensiver im
geschmack und die trockenen zutaten die
habe ich auch schon miteinander
vermischt und die werden jetzt
abwechselnd mit der lauwarmen milch hier
rein gesiebt also 70 auf jeden fall und
verteilt sich das auch besser im teig
und dann ganz langsam einarbeiten
[Musik]
nachdem mir dann die trockenen zutaten
mit der milch nacheinander eingerührt
habt und wirklich geduldig geblieben
seid habt ihr eine solche konsistentes
erinnert so ein bisschen an muffin teig
der wird jetzt aber auch noch ein
bisschen weicher denn wir müssen jetzt
die biomasse unterhemd und um die unter
zu heben bitte unbedingt einen teig
schaber benutzen kein schneebesen keine
maschinen und mit ganz viel liebe
unterheben und am allerbesten in zwei
bis drei schritten
[Musik]
mitunter heben meint übrigens immer dass
er den teig mit dem tisch aber von außen
nach innen bewegt also ihr streicht
wirklich nur am schüssel rand und
irgendwann merkt er dass das ganze schön
unter die teigmasse gehoben ist und
somit ist der teig auch schon fertig mit
ofen ist vorgeheizt und ich hole mir
meine springform das rezept was ich
jetzt habe es für eine 26 cm springform
ausgelegt oder ein tortenring und ich
habe euch aber unten in die infobox eine
datei verlinkt da könnt ihr dann immer
um rechnen falls immer eine kleine
retorte backt oder eine größere und dann
hat er dir eigentlich immer gut
ausgerüstet ich zeig euch jetzt noch
dass ich hier wartet hier unten
unterlegen
also einfach drauf legen den rand drum
herum legt einfach die hände und reißt
den überschuss ab
[Musik]
mein tag habe ich jetzt in die
springform gefüllt und oben am rand noch
mal gerade so glatt gestrichen und viele
fragen mich auch immer was ist der
unterschied zwischen der springform und
den tortenring worin solch backen und
worin werden die böden besser
das kann man so gar nicht sagen wenn ihr
eine hochwertige springform habt dann
könnt ihr auch in der springform
wunderbar backen viele sagen auch ist es
nicht so dass es effizienter ist und
dass man weniger strom verbrauchten den
tortenring das stimmt so nicht dann
müsste die am tag 34 torten backen das
ganze jahr über 365 tage im jahr das ich
da überhaupt etwas ändert und der
verbrauch dadurch wirklich gespart wird
also ich nehme jetzt hier über diesem
rezept eine springform und generell bei
frostigen tagen und wenn ich meinen
festen teig und natürlich auch zum
dekorieren
dann nämlich den tortenring so und ich
gebe das jetzt in den backofen bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze für circa 45
minuten und lass ihn dann an der
oberfläche abgedeckt auf
zimmertemperatur auskühlen
nach dem backen einfach in der form
auskühlen lassen am besten mit einem
tuch obendrüber das habe ich jetzt hier
schon erledigt also mein boden ist
komplett abgekühlt und ich persönlich
mache das immer so wenn ich eine
springform verwende
dann löse ich den boden immer mit einer
winkel palette weil er ist flexibel und
dann mit einem buttermesser klappt das
nicht so gut dann schneidet man sich da
den rand weg und das ist dann eben
unschön und wenn ich einen tortenring
verwendet dann nehme ich meinen
tortenring messer und jetzt gehe ich da
einfach am rand entlang und entferne die
springform ja weil man das noch einen
tortenring benutzt sehr schlaue brücke
brücke die man sicherstellt also ich
mache jetzt hier einmal den rand ab kann
es mal runter springt man sieht man wie
einfach das geht wenn der abgestellt ist
so und jetzt einfach das backpapier
entfernen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr jetzt alle schritte
beachtet habe dann habt ihr den wohl
saftigsten schokoladen boden der auf
dieser welt existiert habe so lange an
diesem rezept getüftelt und ich würde
jetzt auch nichts mehr verändern ich bin
angekommen und das ist für mich das
perfekte rezept falls ihr daraus nur
sahnetorte machen im marzipan torte oder
irgendwas schokolade ist dann benutzt
gerne immer dieses rezept ich verweise
dann auch in meinen videos immer auf
dieses video und jetzt wünsche ich euch
ganzen freude beim nachmachen was ich
aus der torte gemacht hatte sieht er
dann bald und ja bis zum nächsten mal
auf die skating skis
[Musik]